alberon is not the typically
inspirational coach what did you most
enjoy about playing him I've always sort
of been fascinated by coaches that that
appear to derive zero Joy from their
job um but it's always been a clue that
they care more than everybody else about
winning I think there was something
great about the script laying that out
that he was a little bit more removed
almost like a like a a hard to reach dad
the idea that his um his vision in the
beginning is really just about the
mechanics of putting eight different
bodies in a boat and working it all out
in a kind of a mathematical way and then
moving towards you know this this place
of actually understanding each each of
the boys more individually and seeing
their personalities and and and
therefore cracking open a little bit of
warmth you know and love